[Music]
i'm delighted to be here today at the
design education summit we've been on
quite a journey at the nueva school in
california since 2007 when we decided to
implement design thinking over time we
ended up creating a full curriculum
composed of a variety of projects which
spanned many different disciplines so
design thinking as a superpower there
are many challenges in the world and
most of them contain change of some sort
and uncertainty
so what design thinking does is it
allows people to carve a path through
difficult problems that would stop other
people and it does that by giving you a
collection of mindsets and skills
and this graphic shows you a number of
my personal favorites that i find most
effective in helping me solve difficult
problems i'm excited now to share my
model of educational disciplines and the
three pillars of dt that will help you
create original curriculum for your
schools
i realized a few years ago
that each discipline can
be used for design thinking and in fact
each discipline can be divided into two
categories the one on the left is what
we would consider traditional education
the teacher teaches something the
students practice it with guidance from
the teacher they eventually become
independent
and
basically adept at the skill and also
automatic at it
there's generally one right answer there
are many
excellent teaching practices and
textbooks for this and
the traditional educational
you know
traditional education is absolutely
essential right
there's also this other side of the
original creative where it almost feels
a little ambiguous and open-ended and
mysterious and you're not quite sure how
you arrived at the idea
and a lot of
students express distress when they're
faced with
activities like this so a lot of
well-intentioned teachers over time have
removed this from the from the students
workload or homework and um they the
teacher in fact has done this work for
the students by saying okay write a
story said in the past uh around the
history of india right and uh
and they've they've kind of done the
inventive work rather than the students
so each discipline has those um
more uh it's kind of like originality
and
everybody's story would be quite
different
now my final example today is science
science you can see on the left all of
the things that science teachers teach
and
one independent variable careful
measurement
and then on the other side i always was
surprised that
through most of my excellent public
school education i never had to come up
with my own experiment
i was always doing
classic experiments and so then when you
get out and you try to do your own
experiment it's kind of tough and that's
what i see even with kids who are making
experiments for the science fair they're
not quite sure how to do it
so
design thinking is perfect for that and
i decided to have creating the
experiment as the focus for my
brainstorm and so i basically the way
real scientists do it is they observe
something they notice it they research
it they talk to other scientists they
dig further they wonder about it they
hypothesize different things they do
switching over to the prototyping they
do
[Music]
various different prototypes to see what
results they're getting and that gives
them more insights and then they go back
to the need finding and do more research
on
new theories they have and eventually
they go into the brainstorming of ways
to create the experiment and the any
apparatus they might need
so
that's what science really looks like
and design thinking is preparing them
for that design thinking is powerful and
i think the reason it is is you have an
effective fluidity between both the
traditional knowledge and skills and the
um more open-ended creativity and by
going back and forth between those two
knowing that both
both of them are essential
makes you very powerful prepares
students for the uncertainty in their
future lives prepares them to be leaders
who don't have to be told what to do and
it empowers everyone to both
professionally and personally while
building confidence
[Music]
you